you're probably familiar with the
general term factor so if i were to say
what are the factors of 12 you could say
well what are the whole numbers that i
can multiply by another whole number to
get 12. so for examples you could say
things like well i could multiply 1
times 12 to get 12. so you could say
that 1 is a factor of 12. you could even
say that 12 is a factor of 12. you could
say 2 times 6 is equal to 12. so you
could say that 2 is a factor of 12 and
that 6 is also a factor of 12 and of
course 3 times 4 is also 12. so both 3
and 4 are factors of 12. so if you said
well what are the factors of 12 and
you've seen this before you'd say well
you could say 1 2 3 4
6 and 12. those are all factors of 12.
you could also phase it the other way
around so let me just give an example so
if i were to pick on 3 i could say that
is
a factor
factor
of 12. or to phrase it slightly
differently i could say that 12
is divisible
divisible
12 is divisible
by 3.
now what i want to do in this video is
extend this idea of being a factor or
divisibility into the algebraic world
so for example
if i were to take
x
y so this is a monomial with an integer
coefficient 3 is an integer right over
here
and if i were to multiply it with
another monomial with an integer
coefficient i don't know let's say times
negative 2
x squared
y to the third power
what is this going to be equal to
well this would be equal to
if we multiply the coefficients 3 times
negative 2
is going to be negative 6
x times x squared is x to the third
power
and then y times y to the third is y
to the 4th power
and so what we could say is if we wanted
to say factors of negative 6 x to the
3rd y to the 4th we could say that 3xy
is a factor of this just as an example
so let me write that down we could write
that
x y
is a factor of
is
a factor
of
6 of negative 6 x to the third power
y to the fourth or we could phrase that
the other way around we could say that
negative six x to the third
y to the fourth is divisible by
is
divisible
is divisible
by
3xy so hopefully you're seeing the
parallels if i'm taking these two
monomials with integer coefficients and
i multiply them and i get this other in
this case this other monomial i could
say that either one of these and there's
actually other factors of this but i
could say either one of these is a
factor of this monomial or we could say
that negative six x to the third y to
the four is divisible by
one of its factors and we could even
extend this to binomials or polynomials
for example
if i were to take
if i were to take let me scroll down a
little bit
whoops if i
were to take let me
say
x
plus three
and i wanted to multiply it times
x
plus
seven
we know that this is going to be equal
to if i were to write it as a trinomial
it's going to be x times x
so x squared and then it's going to be
3x plus 7x so plus
10x and if any of this looks familiar we
have a lot of videos where we go in
detail of multiplying binomials like
this and then 3 times 7 is 21
plus
21.
and so because i've multiplied these two
in this case binomials or we could
consider themselves to be polynomials
polynomials or binomials with integer
coefficients notice the coefficients
here they're 1 1 the constants here
they're all integers because i'm dealing
with all integers here we could say that
either one of these binomials is a
factor of this trinomial
or we could say this trinomial is
divisible by either one of these so let
me write that down so i could say i'll
just pick on x plus 7. we could say that
x
plus 7 is a factor
is a factor
of
x squared
plus 10 x
plus 21 or we could say that x squared
plus 10 x plus 21 is divisible by
is
divisible
by i could say x plus 3 or i could say x
plus 7 is divisible by
x plus
7. and the key is is that both of these
binomials or even if we were dealing
with polynomials we are dealing with
things that have integer we're dealing
with things that have integer
coefficients